all right marty
where do you where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
i'm from vallejo and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were a kid
no i didn't
who raised you my um
my my uh my dad i guess
where was your mom my mom was uh
i i was found as a as as as as a as a
as as as as a a little child with the
with with the with the famous note
so uh i don't know i never met my my
real
my real blood parents before so the
father that raised you was just somebody
who kind of
adopted you yes how was your childhood
it was pretty pretty pretty foul i'm
known as
not locked up in a room with with no
lock on it
for how long since uh
before i was uh 16.
look i mean so you you there was there
was child abuse and stuff like that
going on yes
what kind of stuff was going on just uh
not not not not not getting anything to
eat
for uh
how long did you go without eating
almost almost every day i mean i i
wouldn't eat until my
my my my my hair my hair and our dad
would
come home from work and finally finally
i finally get to come out outside my
room and get some dinner
so your your adopted family was was good
to you or
they were mean to you yeah they they
were they were they were
my dad my dad tried he tried
he tried for a long time but they fought
every night
over me or or or money
were you the only child yes yes no no i
wasn't
i had uh two two uh
here on earth uh brothers
what kind of kid were you in high school
i was pretty good in
kitten high school especially after
after after i
left home i went still with my class and
my aunt class
she uh she took me shopping for the
first time i got
some real nice school clothes and i got
my girlfriend
real real real real real real
real real real real uh real fast like
a girl named my janet uh janet
uh
janet fisher
so your aunt gladys was a blood relative
of yours
no she wasn't blood but she was a a a
a a a relative of mine
so she was like some relation to your
adopted parents yes yes okay
to my she she she's my my my hearing
those dads
hearing our dad's uh
brother-in-law brother and putting in a
bit of a [ __ ]
and you you went on your own at what age
i was almost since i was probably 15 15
16. where'd you go with that age
i want to stay with some some some from
some
some uh relatives of mine
until uh
you know i ended up ending up stealing
some money from from from what from one
of my uh
relative kids because my aunt got a big
argument with with my parents my parents
weren't sending them any money
i didn't realize how much food i was
eating out of the house
and my aunt she told me she told me she
she can't deal with it she told me to
get to get the [ __ ] out of
of of her house and i did
but i remember finding some finding some
money
inside a dresser that my cousin told me
to
go get a wrap for for her her boyfriend
mark
and next to the rap was a big wad of
money
and uh so i remember that word of money
so i remember uh when my aunt told me to
get the [ __ ] out
i said well i'm not gonna leave
empty-handed i'm only 16 years old
i got nowhere to go at 16. so i took the
money and i went all the way to uh
west west west uh
for west virg ver ver
ver ver west ver virginia
when i was only 16.
do you have kids of your own yes i do
and where are they i got a son who's
a a a a a harvard law school uh
graduate believe it or not his name is
named his name it's christian philip
gills
have his habits have his tattoo on my
chest christian phillip
this is your son yes do you stay in
contact with your family
your son uh i've tried to
so today you're living nintendo one
yes i'm out there in the tl and i'm out
there in the uh
on the streets of san francisco right
now
and how long have you been living in the
tenderloin
for about two three three
three three three and a half years or so
and you're living in a tent or just on
the street
they were not living living out there on
the on on on
on on on on on on
the the uh the streets
no tent no tent
and what do you do for money now how do
you survive
i was getting a a ssi
and uh i haven't been on fire my uh
my uh i have
what they call uh
pay pay pay payees through uh
through a place called walden house and
have them have been able to find
them find my uh and be able to find them
my uh my uh to
uh pays named the net and
and annette they're they're
they're my pays okay i have
i've been i've been eating out of
garbage cans since then
what uh do you use any of the drugs that
are on the street
do i do i do i do i do i do i do some uh
crank out there and crank is
is what it's it's it's meth crystal man
yes yeah how long have you been using
i've been using off and on i only need
only only a shot
a shot every every month or so so a shot
a good shot will do me i haven't had a
good shot in probably
three three three or four years
i can't remember i think i paid a guy uh
uh one hundred dollars to
to shoot me one time to uh
to uh fix me to uh
to uh
do you drink alcohol sometimes as well
no i don't
i don't i don't like alcohol too much i
drink every now and then
to come down off of crack
have you ever been in a mental health
facility or gutting counseling or
anything like that
no
when did you first do using drugs
about three four four four four
no about seven seven seven years ago
in uh 2012.
do you have any friends i have uh i have
some
uh uh uh more like uh
associates just people you meet on the
street
i have some good friends and family out
there who
who don't use it whatsoever
do you think anything your childhood
might have led you into this
lifestyle of homelessness and drugs and
stuff like that
it sounds like your childhood was kind
of rough yes it has been
how do you think you've changed from all
these years of living like this
i've changed for the better i've changed
i've changed
it's kind of hard to explain after all
all the
i went through a whole lot for a lot a
lot of people's souls i really did
i am whom whom whom it came down to it
came down to me
have you heard bad things happen to you
living in the streets
not no no
people leave you alone pretty much you
have to do
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life how old are you
i'm 53 53
what do you think the most important
thing you've learned in your life don't
don't trust anyone
do you feel you have anyone you can go
to in a time of need
no i don't i don't don't i don't really
re
re we uh remember
somebody my mom my my family's phone
number
i don't know if if if if my dad's even
living right now
i haven't had him call my dad in a while
after after that situation happened and
when i was stuck in a you know
you a a ll in a a elevator
with with the with this girl
what happened in an elevator with the
girl she wanted me to call my dad up and
get some money from him
and i did i like i lied to my dad about
why why why i needed some money
my dad ended up finding out about it
so mario how will you spend the rest of
the day it's a saturday morning here in
san francisco what will you do the rest
of the day
i mean i'm used to money that that that
you're going to uh
give me to uh probably probably
probably go go go buy me some uh
some crystal
and and and get high with it because it
it it helps you stay warm at night
that's basically your existence every
day down here pretty much
do you have hope of a different life for
you for yourself
yes i do i'm hoping to get
dropped off by my family in in in the
dropped off the seat
but you haven't spoken to your family in
a long time no
you don't have their phone number and
they don't know where you are probably
right
no
have you been in love before marty have
i been in love before yes
yes i have
were you married before no
what was the best time of your life
the best the worst time the best time
when i first saw my uh my my my
my my my my my
my uh future queen i fell and i fell in
in love with as soon as i seen her i
said myself
who is that i go she's walking with the
purpose she's walking with the purpose
one day i will marry her and she would
never never never never never never
never never never never never never
never never
never never never never never never
never never
she would never be be be
b b b b b
should never be b b
between me
all right marty thank you so much for
talking with me and uh good luck with
wherever you go from here man
thank you so i appreciate your time
thank you man
all right
you